>> Colleen Shogan:
Good afternoon.
My name is Colleen Shogan.
I work at the Library
of Congress.
Welcome to the 18th Annual
National Book Festival.
A couple of housekeeping
items before we get started.
Please silence your cell
phones if you haven't already.
And there will be time for a
Q&A at the end of the session
so please be sure to
save your questions.
I'm honored to be joined
onstage today by Tara Westover,
the author of Educated.
Tara grew up in rural Idaho.
She's a graduate of
Brigham Young University,
and she also received
her PhD in history
from Cambridge University
in the UK.
And I think that's all I'm
going to say about Tara
and her biography for now
because I think we're going
to get into a lot of the details
in our conversation today.
If you haven't read Educated,
I highly recommend it.
I picked it up at the beginning
of a trans-Atlantic flight
from Europe back to Washington,
DC, and I didn't put it
down the entire flight.
And that's really the
marker of a terrific book.
But I am not the only person
who thinks Educated
is a terrific book
because a few weeks ago
President Barack Obama issued a
list of his top five books
that he read this summer
and Tara's book,
Educated, was on that list.
[ Applause ]
So how did you find
out about that?
Did President Obama tweet you?
Did he text you ahead of time?
Or how did you find out?
>> Tara Westover: I had been
told that he was reading it.
>> Colleen Shogan: Mmhmm.
>> Tara Westover: But I don't
think I took that very --
no, I'd been told that he'd
said he was going to read it.
>> Colleen Shogan: OK.
>> Tara Westover:
Which, I know what I'm
like when I say I'm
going to read a book.
And I thought, yeah,
sure you -- [laughing].
>> Colleen Shogan: Right.
>> Tara Westover: So no,
I wasn't expecting it.
I went. I had a lunch
with a friend.
It was very nice.
And then I left and I did that
thing that we all do now as soon
as we stop talking to someone
and we're alone --
we look at our phone.
And I checked my email and
there was an email from my agent
who said, "This has
just happened!"
[Laughter] And yeah, it
was a lovely surprise.
And then a couple of
days later I got a call.
I was at my house and then my
phone rang and I answered it.
And they said, "Do you think
you have time this afternoon
for a call from President
Obama?"
[Whispering] I was like
-- [speaking again] yeah!
[Laughter] I can fit that in
with all the other former
presidents who are calling me.
[Laughing] Maybe at 2:15.
So he really generously
called me
and was just really
thoughtful, kind.
He has a lot of things
going on in his life.
He did not have to do that.
So I mean, that was pretty --
I've had some weird
things happen in my life
and that was pretty weird.
>> Colleen Shogan: Yep.
>> Tara Westover: You know?
[Laughter] That was
right up there with some
of the strangest things that
I never thought would happen.
>> Colleen Shogan: So to start
us out, in your book I think one
of the strengths of the book is
your really vivid descriptions
of where you grew up.
And the setting of your
book is so important
because it sets the entire
framework for the story.
So in your own words can
you talk to us a little bit
about the place where
you grew up?
>> Tara Westover: Yeah.
I was raised the
youngest of seven children
on this mountain in Idaho.
And a lot of people know
we didn't go to school.
We didn't go to the doctor.
I didn't have a birth
certificate.
We had these quite radical
aspects of our lives.
I think some people think
that that means it was a bleak
childhood and it really wasn't.
It was a pretty happy childhood.
There were a lot of
beautiful things.
We had horses.
We had a junkyard.
But I know that doesn't sound
really great but it kind
of was a lot of the time.
I mean, if you ever want to
have a really good game of hide
and seek or treasure hunting
or any kind of game at all,
having your own junkyard
is pretty amazing.
You know? We'd go to
my grandmother's house
and we'd play that lava
game where you pretend
like everything is lava except
the pillows you put on the floor
but do that with junk cars
that you can jump from.
Like, it was great!
So a lot of really wonderful
things about my childhood
and then there were some kind
of difficult things about it.
So not being able to go
to school was difficult.
I never had any friends.
I never went to another
kid's house.
I called them public school
kids and I never had any friends
who were public school kids.
I never went to their house.
They never came to mine.
And so there were these
kind of slightly darker,
more difficult elements.
And eventually I
would go to college.
I would not really know what I
was doing or why I was doing it.
But I would teach myself
enough algebra to pass the ACT
and I would wind
up at a university
and that would be a pretty
big shock [chuckling].
And then life would
change pretty dramatically.
But my childhood itself --
yeah, I think like a lot
of people's lives
it wasn't one thing.
It was mixed.
>> Colleen Shogan: So your
book is about your own journey
to become educated and
your educational journey.
It's also about your
relationship with your family.
Can you talk a little bit
about your mother and father
in particular and their
views on education?
>> Tara Westover: My parents, I
think they were quite idealistic
about education when my
older brothers were young.
My father was kind of
paranoid about the government,
about many different things.
He thought the government had
been infiltrated by something
like the Illuminati, this
nefarious organization
that was corrupting everything.
And he believed public
education was a part of that.
So he didn't want us in the
schools because he was not --
he didn't want them
teaching us things
that he didn't agree with.
So that was, I think, when my
parents first made the decision
to homeschool their kids.
I think they had a
fairly idealistic view
that they would -- at least
my mother, I think thought
that she could provide a
better education at home.
But that just kind of gave way,
fell by the wayside so that
by the time that I came
along and my three older --
the three that are
just older than me --
there wasn't a lot of
by way of education.
There were -- I mean, I was
definitely taught to read by one
of my older brothers,
so I was literate.
Reading was important
to my family.
But it wasn't -- I
never took an exam.
I never wrote an essay.
I never remember anything
like a formal lecture
which is why I could
arrive at BYU --
and there's serious questions
to how I got into BYU [laughing]
because I wasn't qualified.
But you know, that's how I
could arrive at a university
when I was 17 and go
into a classroom and say,
"what is this word: Holocaust?"
I hadn't heard it before.
And I'd never heard of
the civil rights movement.
There were so many
things I didn't know.
I thought Europe was a
country, not a continent.
That was very confusing.
And so I had this education
that was incredibly spotty
because it had just never
been formal in any way.
But I think my parents,
strangely enough,
I don't think it's that they
completely didn't value it.
It just didn't happen.
And I think their
idea of education was
such that it was entirely
kind of your responsibility
and if you wanted to learn
something you should go
learn it.
But there were difficulties
with that.
You know, not everyone can
teach themselves calculus.
I don't think I could do that.
I sort of taught
myself trigonometry
and it didn't go great.
>> Colleen Shogan: So instead of
following a homeschool program
or going to a public
school or a private school,
you worked with your father in
the scrapyard, in the junkyard.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
And was that -- did you
learn anything from that?
Was it an unconventional
form of education?
>> Tara Westover: People
always said in my family
that one thing we know how to do
is we really know how to work.
And we really do.
We're really good workers.
And I think I did learn a
really good work ethic working
with my dad.
I think people judge
my dad really harshly.
And I struggle with that because
I tried to write him the way
that I see him and the
way that I think he is.
We got injured a lot in my dad's
junkyard, really horrifically,
and it was completely
unnecessary.
A few safety precautions,
basic ones [chuckles].
Nothing elaborate here.
You know, harnesses.
And people wouldn't have
gotten hurt the way they did.
And then of course because
he had these beliefs
about doctors we didn't
go to the hospital.
And it's hard for me
to convince people
that this wasn't malicious.
You know, my dad loved his
kids but he put his kids
in danger a lot and then once
they were hurt he didn't give
them medical attention.
And that is hard for
people to square.
It's hard for me to square.
It's hard to square that circle.
I've squared it for myself
by believing that I --
my thing is that my dad
has a mental illness.
I think he's bipolar.
For some reason he doesn't
have that bone in his head
that tells him when
something is dangerous.
And so he would routinely ask
us to do things or tell us
to do things that
were so dangerous.
But the redeeming fact,
I suppose, is, you know,
my dad never had us do
anything or put us in any danger
that he wouldn't
have put himself in.
So it was not the case that
my father would, you know,
if we were injured not take
us to a doctor but then
if he was injured take
himself to a doctor.
I mean, the worst
injury that happened
in my father's junkyard
happened to my father.
He was standing next to a car.
He was removing a fuel tank.
Because he just doesn't think
rationally about things,
he decided not to drain the
fuel before he lit a torch
and started to remove the tank.
And you know, fuel is flammable.
So the car exploded and
he was burned terribly,
unbelievably bad.
And it was months of
recovering and he nearly died.
And of course, my parents
because of the beliefs
that they have, they did not
take him to the hospital.
They treated that at home.
And the pain was unimaginable.
But so I tell this story
because I think it shows
for my father he was doing what
he thought the right thing was.
You might disagree and it's
hard for people to understand.
For my father, I
think what love looked
like for his children was not
taking them to the doctor,
not taking my brother to the
doctor when he lit his leg
on fire and it was
terribly burned,
because he sincerely
believed it.
So he wasn't an unloving father.
He didn't put us through things
and then be kinder to himself.
These were his beliefs.
And so the story is it's
a little more complicated
than what do you do when
people treat you badly
because they don't
care about you.
It's more a story of what do
you do when you love someone
and they love you and there is
just something disfunctional
about it that is harmful to you?
And that is a harder
situation to resolve.
And I think it's probably
one that most people face.
I don't know a lot of
people who their trouble
with their parents is just
a completely evil parent
that doesn't care
for them at all.
I'm sure there are
some parents like that.
But I think it's -- you know,
a family is incredibly nuanced.
And for me, writing
the book, that was one
of the things I really wanted
to tease apart which is
to say I love my father, I
think he's a good person,
I think he loves me.
I think he wants what he
thinks is best for me.
And [laughs] they're not
always the same thing
as what I think is
best for myself.
And how do we navigate that?
And what if we can't navigate it
and how do we accept the outcome
of not being able
to navigate it?
>> Colleen Shogan: For most
of your childhood you thought
that you would follow in
your mother's footsteps,
that you would study
to become an herbalist.
You might take over her
business as a midwife.
But then at some point -- you
changed your mind at some point.
Can you tell us about how
you made that decision not
to follow the path that
you thought you were going
to follow?
>> Tara Westover: I think it
was -- you know, it's funny.
I was just flipping
through the book.
I'm going to read a little bit.
>> Colleen Shogan: Sure.
>> Tara Westover: Because
it's here and it's open
and it's completely relevant.
It's what you just said.
[ Laughter ]
>> Colleen Shogan:
We did not plan it.
[Laughing]
>> Tara Westover: No, no
planning and no planning
in my life [laughing].
So I'm just going to
do two paragraphs.
Don't worry.
It won't be long.
Three. I'd come to
BYU to study music
so that one day I could direct a
church choir but that semester,
the fall of my junior
year, I didn't enroll
in a single music course.
I could not have explained why
I dropped Advanced Music Theory
in favor of Geography and
Comparative Politics or gave
up Sight Singing to take
up History of the Jews.
But when I'd seen those
courses in the catalog
and read their titles aloud,
I had felt something infinite
and I wanted a taste
of that infinity.
For four months I attended
lectures on geography
and history and politics.
I learned about Margaret
Thatcher and the 38th parallel
and the cultural revolution.
I learned about parliamentary
politics
and electoral systems
around the world.
I learned about the Jewish
Diaspora and the strange history
at the Protocols of
the Elders of Zion.
By the end of the semester the
world felt big and it was hard
to imagine returning to
the mountain, to a kitchen,
or even to a piano in the
room next to the kitchen.
This caused a kind
of crisis in me.
My love of music and my desire
to study it had been compatible
with my idea of what a woman is.
My love of history and politics
and world affairs was not and
yet they called to me.
I don't know as though there's a
straightforward answer to that.
I think I'd been raised
with a very strong idea
of what my life was
supposed to look like.
And there were a number
of alternative paths
that you could take that
all followed very closely
to that path.
So you could go to
college and study music
so that you could
be a piano teacher
because that was complementary
to being a wife and a homemaker
and that was very much
what I was raised to be.
And there wasn't really
a lot of other avenues.
There were a couple of
things you could do as well
that might be commensurate
with that.
And I had a big struggle at BYU
because I was drawn to things
that by my own definition of
myself and my own definition
of what it meant to be
female didn't add up.
I did not understand why
I as a woman was drawn
to what I thought
of as unwomanly things
but I definitely was.
And it took me a couple of years
of kind of wrestling with that.
And I think I was at
Cambridge, really,
before I started reading
a bit of feminist text.
I was in no way ready
for anything
that most feminists would
call feminism [laughing],
but I stumbled on this
passage in John Stuart Mill.
And I've read a lot of
feminist stuff since then.
And this is still the
most powerful thing
that has resonated
with me, personally.
It's a line that he says.
He says, "of the
nature of women,
nothing final can be known."
And his argument is all
the social pressure.
Women have been cajoled and
pushed and defined to themselves
and changed in so
many different ways.
And now we have no idea
what they're capable of.
We just don't know.
We don't know what they are
because we've been
deforming them for so long.
And that was, you know,
that whole absence
of knowledge was
so appealing to me.
I mean, of the nature of women
nothing final can be known.
Because to me what that felt
like was, whatever I'm drawn to,
whatever I want to
be, I am a woman.
So that must be OK.
And I don't need to find
external definitions
of what I should be
like, what I should love,
what I should want to do.
I can just discard all
of that and I can say,
definitionally you can't say
that women don't like politics,
that women don't like history
because I am one and I do.
So that was incredibly
-- that, just, absence,
to take all of what we think
we know and throw it away
and make your decisions based on
what you think is right for you.
It was really wonderful for
me and it had nothing to do
with not wanting family
and not wanting children
or rejecting that way of life.
It just had to do with accepting
other parts of who I was.
>> Colleen Shogan: When you were
at BYU it was very difficult
for you when you started.
But even in your first semester
that you were there you
still got very good grades.
You were very successful.
How did you do that?
Do you look back at that moment
in time and are you in sort
of awe of what you were able
to do and the transition
and the changes that
you overcame?
How were you successful after
going from no formal education
to a very competitive school?
>> Tara Westover:
[Sighs] I suffered a lot
of that first semester
[laughing].
It was kind of awful, actually.
I remember that.
It was not a happy time.
There was a lot of -- I would
say my first two years at BYU
where I was learning out
of fear because I had
to have a scholarship.
At BYU to get a scholarship --
I had to have a 3.9 or above.
[Laughs] Which is
basically, I think,
most semesters I could
get four A's and one A-.
If I got two A-'s
that was risky.
And this is insane.
And I knew I had to have it
because I couldn't come back.
Without that money, there
was no way I was coming back.
And so it was just terror.
I just learned -- I did
the homework obsessively.
I did every extra credit thing.
I did everything I could.
When I took a math class, which
was a bad idea [laughing],
I just killed myself
for that class.
And I failed many of the exams.
And then I made a deal with the
professor that if I got 100%,
missed nothing on the final,
that he would forget all the
other horrifying tests I'd taken
and he would just
score that one.
And so just all I did
for a month was just
study for that exam.
And I don't mean
all I did, like,
I studied an hour or two a day.
I mean, that's all I did.
And you know, that's
one of the things
for me -- getting a grant.
I'd finally applied for FAFSA.
It took this lovely Mormon
bishop, like kind of equivalent
of a pastor, who spent
weeks trying to convince me
that it wasn't evil to
accept government money
and I was very resistant
to that.
[Laughing] But eventually I
filled out this application.
A check came for $4,000.
And I think that was the moment
I stopped learning out of fear
and started learning
because I wanted to
and I was interested
in the material.
And that was when the shift
really started to take hold
of being able to follow
what felt compelling to me
and what I wanted to learn
and what I wanted to do.
That little amount of money
made such a difference to me.
It's difficult to even
compare the way that I studied
and the way that I attended
school and what school meant
to me before that
money and after
that money are completely
different.
>> Colleen Shogan: I think, for
me, the most disturbing part
of your book and your story
stems from your relationship
with your brother Shawn, who was
certainly emotionally abusive
and at times physical
abusive towards you.
As your education progressed,
how did that inform you
to help you understand that
that relationship was a
disfunctional one?
>> Tara Westover: Yeah, I
called the book Educated.
And I think it's about education
but it's not about degrees
and it's not about certificates
and it's not about the job
that you can get if you
have the right degree
and the right certificate.
I think it's about the ways
that education makes you a
different person and for me
that took a lot of
different shapes.
One of the shapes it took
was that I became someone
that was able to have
different ideas in my head
than the people around me.
And I'd never been
that person before.
I had grown up in an isolated
intellectual environment
where my father gave us the
ideas that he wanted us to have
because he believed that
was the right thing for us,
but that's essentially
what he did.
And so his version of history,
his version of everything,
that's what we learned.
And that bled over in some ways.
I was quite used to people
telling me what had happened.
So my brother Shawn,
he would be violent.
He would be not -- yeah, I
was going to say aggressive
but just flat out violent.
And almost immediately
after that would happen
he would convince me
that it hadn't happened
or that it had been a game
or that it had been this
kind of fun experience.
I mean, there were
times that he would --
I mean, there's one example
where he grabbed me by my hair
and he hauled me
down the hallway
and he shoved my
head in the toilet.
And a friend of mine
witnessed it.
I was 17 so I actually
had a friend.
And later he said to me, Shawn
said to me, "it's just a game"
and "I thought we
were having fun"
and "if something was wrong you
really should have told me."
And I went to my friend,
Charles, who'd seen it and tried
to convince him that it was this
game and he wasn't having it.
And at some point
in my time at BYU,
and it wasn't too long
later, that began to shift.
And I began to have my own ideas
about what was happening to me.
And I think it was the
same shift with my father.
My father -- there was
a time when I was at BYU
that my father came and he
was giving me this lecture
about Jewish, basically about
these conspiracy theories
that run wild sometimes.
He thought Jewish people were
going to start World War III
so they could consolidate
their power
and he had some pretty
horrifying ideas about that.
And I recognized some of
the things he was saying
because I'd taken that
course in Jewish history.
And I knew he was
quoting from the Protocols
of the Elders of Zion.
He didn't.
He would have been
horrified to think
that he was quoting something
that Hitler had liked.
You know. But I knew
the history of the text.
I knew that it had been
discredited as a forgery.
I didn't know how
he got hold of it,
but I knew what it
was and he didn't.
It was the first time
that I think I'd been able
to hear my father speak with
such confidence and authority
in this voice that I'd trusted
more than any other voice.
And I was able to think
to myself, "interesting
that you think that but I
don't, I don't think that."
And it was the same switch
that happened with my brother.
Something changed where
he would say to me --
there was a difficult
incident in a parking lot
where he essentially assaulted
me and he cracked my wrist.
I think he probably broke it.
And it took months to heal.
But within a few minutes of it
or within a few hours he tried
to convince me that
it had been a game,
that we were having a good time,
that he hadn't had any idea
that anything was wrong.
And that was the first night
that even though he told me
that, what I wrote in my journal
that night was I wrote my
version of the events which was
that it had been terrifying,
that I'd been screaming at him
to stop, that he really hurt me,
that I had no idea
why he was doing that
but I had definitely asked
him, I had told him not to.
And then I wrote his
version which was
that it had been this
fun, nice, little game.
And I didn't know which
one was right, like,
would not have that moment.
And within a couple of days
I was prioritizing his,
if I'm honest with you.
It wasn't a complete progression
but it was the first time,
I think, that my brother
attempted to pose his point
of view, he attempted
to dominate me
in this very specific
way, and at the end
of that process there were
still two minds present.
There were two distinct
minds present
who had had two different
experiences
and I hadn't just yielded
my interpretation of things
or my experience
of things to his.
He had one idea of what
happened and that was fine
but I knew what I'd experienced.
And I think education, it
has to be more than something
that you undertake to get a
degree to get a better job.
I think at its absolute best
it needs to be the acquisition
of the skills that allow
you to live a fuller live,
that allow you to
participate in a meaningful way
in the making of your own mind.
And I think a part of
that is just going to have
to be learning and
getting the opportunity
to assess a wide variety of
information and a wide variety
of different perspectives and
decide what you actually think.
And that's how you develop that
skill, that really crucial skill
to have people in your life that
you respect, that you admire,
that you trust, that
are important to you,
but you don't necessarily have
to just think whatever
they think,
that you can have
your own thoughts
and your own perspectives
and it can be true
of conspiracy theories
about, you know,
somewhat anti-Semitic
conspiracy theories [laughing],
or it can be the
truth of your own life
and what's happening to you.
But I think that kind
of independence of mind,
that's what education
should be about.
And it should change the way
that you live and interact
with people, I think, if
it's a real education.
>> Colleen Shogan: As the
story progresses -- oh, yeah.
[ Applause ]
As your story progresses,
your educational
achievements are building up.
They proliferate.
And your relationship with your
family -- most of your family,
not your entire family, most
of your family -- deteriorates.
So it becomes an
inverse relationship.
So when did you realize
that these two things
that were clearly
very important to you,
these two things
weren't going to march
in concert with each other?
And how did you deal with that?
>> Tara Westover: I think
there's different kinds
of realization.
There's the realization
that makes you,
that you're actually aware.
Then there's the realization
that makes you repress.
[Laughing] And I think
there were a lot of years
that I was aware of it in a way
that made me not deal with it
at all and just pretend
like it wasn't happening.
For my family, change was
always going to be hard and one
of the ways -- I said education
should make you a different
person and it made me
a different person.
It made me the kind of person
who wasn't necessarily going
to tolerate the behavior from
my brother that I had been.
And that was never going to
go down well in my family.
It took me a long
time to realize that.
It took me a long time to
realize that there was nothing
in the way that I
approached my parents.
There's nothing in the
way that I said it.
There's nothing in
the way that I behaved
that made them not accept that.
They were just never going to
and it was always
going to be an issue.
It's so easy in those situations
to blame yourself and think, oh,
if I'd said it in
a different way.
No. I don't think that
was ever going to happen.
And so there was going
to be a point, I suppose,
where that was going
to come to a head.
And I don't know when
exactly I accepted it.
I think probably I
accepted it several years
after it was true, actually.
I think there was a lot
of magical thinking there.
There was a lot of thinking, I
can say this, I can fix this.
There was a lot of me
thinking I can change people
and of course you can't.
You can't change other people.
You can only change yourself
and that's hard enough.
And so I think it
took me a long time.
I confronted my parents
about my brother.
They immediately told
him what I'd said.
He disowned me.
Then my parents developed
this really lovely idea
that I was possessed which
was the way they tried
to explain why I'd said
what I said about him.
And after a couple
of years of that,
I became estranged from them.
And that was my choice.
But even then I still
thought I could fix it.
And fundamentally it was
because I wanted to believe
that I could change them.
I could make them into people
that I could have in my life.
And I couldn't.
And so then I had a
lot of guilt for a lot
of years about that decision.
I made a decision to
walk away from them
and then you feel
like a bad person.
You feel like a bad kid.
You feel like -- are
there any reasons
that a child can walk away
from their own parents?
And for me for a long time I
thought no, no, there are not.
There are no reasons
that make that OK.
And those were some
of my angriest years
because I didn't
feel like I deserved
to have made that decision.
So I was constantly relitigating
in my mind every awful thing
that they had done,
everything I resented them
for because I was
trying to justify myself.
And it took me a lot
of years to realize,
if I could just accept the
decision on my own terms,
that I did it for myself --
it was nothing to
do with my father.
It wasn't about whether
he deserved it.
It was just because I needed it.
And once I made it about what I
deserved, about valuing myself,
and not about being angry
with someone else, you know,
things got a lot more peaceful
and I no longer feel that need
to just constantly
relitigate everything
that I dislike about my parents.
I try to keep it in my mind
because I don't want to go back
and get in that situation again.
But then I can also be
someone who has good memories
about my family and
I can be someone
who has beautiful memories.
And that's important, I think.
I lived my life for a
couple of years as someone
who had no good memories.
Everything in my life had
just turned to rot and range
and anger because I was
so mad at my parents
for what had happened.
And it's been a much nicer stage
of life to get to the point
where I value my past.
And there was that time
where I couldn't value it
because it was painful
to lose it.
And I thought, well, I just
have to say that it was all crap
and it was all terrible and
there's nothing good there
and so I don't care that I've
lost them because they were bad.
And that was kind of painful
because then I didn't
have any good memories.
And it was a long process to get
to the point where I can say,
"there was value there;
the love was real;
there were really wonderful
things about them; and I've lost
that and that was a
decision and I stand
by that decision
for my own sake."
But I don't have to devalue what
I had just because I've lost it.
And then I can be someone who
had a beautiful childhood.
I can also be someone who
had a difficult childhood.
>> Colleen Shogan: Last
question before we turn it
over for questions
from the audience.
So, can you catch
us up on your life
since you published the memoir?
What do you have planned next?
Are you writing another book?
What's next for you
professionally?
>> Tara Westover: I am trying
to put together a documentary
about rural education.
Rural kids tend to struggle
a bit more transitioning
from high school
to the next stage.
Whether that's trade
school or university,
they tend to struggle a bit
more, I think especially
because of the economic crisis.
You know, small towns are sort
of shrinking for the first time
in the United States
history and I think a lot
because of big agriculture.
Family farms are dying.
So there's a struggle that's
going on there that I saw
when I was growing up
that I've continued to see
as I go back there that I
kind of want to explore.
>> Colleen Shogan: OK, terrific.
I'm sure there's
a lot of questions
from our audience for Tara.
If you have them, please,
there's a number of microphones.
>> Hi. I was curious.
You address it at the end of
your book but I was wondering
since the book has, you know,
gotten such rave reviews
and become such a success,
what your relationship is now
with any members of your
family, with your family,
or what they think of it.
>> Tara Westover: I would say
with some I've gotten closer
to them and with
some it's been rocky.
And I wouldn't have predicted
who those people would be.
There were people that I thought
they were reading the book
before I even agreed to publish
it, they were happy with it,
and then it's been a
real struggle with them
that it's become -- you know, we
didn't think this would happen.
This isn't necessarily
what we signed up for.
You know, me even.
This is -- it's great but it's
different than what I imagined.
And then there are
family members --
I have aunts and cousins that
have been incredibly supportive
that I wasn't expecting that
kind of support from them.
And so I feel like I've gained a
lot of family from the process.
But you know, it's a difficult
thing, this kind of story.
There's no way around
it, I think.
If you're going to tell
stories about your life,
it might be difficult
for people.
And it was difficult for
me, in a way, the decisions
that I made to write the book.
And it's a process.
So I would say in general
pretty much the book --
people have responded the way
that you would expect in a way
but there have been
some surprises.
>> Hi. I was wondering if
you had strong feelings
about keeping your experiences
from being replicated
in other families,
about homeschooling
and your lack of education.
>> Tara Westover: Yeah,
the homeschooling one is a
really difficult question
because I think some people do
a fantastic job homeschooling.
My brother Tyler
homeschools his children
and I've never seen
better adjusted,
educated kids [laughs].
I've just never seen it.
But I think that it's
a difficult question.
It's hard to regulate because
you can't compare one family
of kids.
You know, you can't rank them.
What do you rank them against?
Do you rank them
against the local school?
And what if they
have disabilities?
And I don't have a
policy solution for that.
But I would try to give parents
a bit of advice, I guess,
which is I would say
think about why you want
to homeschool your kids.
If the reason you want to
homeschool your kids is
because you want to keep them
from getting access to points
of view that you disagree with,
I would say that's probably less
about education and
probably more about control.
And but if you want
to educate your kids
because you really believe
you can give them access
to more points of view and more
ideas and more ways of thinking
about the world,
I've seen that work.
>> Hi. I loved your book.
The whole time I was reading it,
I wanted to know what was
the moment or decision
where you decided, "I
should share this story"
because obviously
it's very personal.
There could be repercussions.
I come from a very
similar background to you
and that's kind of a
question I deal with.
What is the good of sharing it
but also how it can be
misunderstood or have, you know,
blowback to the people you love
or even are estranged from?
So I'm just really
interested in why you decided
to write it and share it.
>> Tara Westover: Yeah.
I think the typical way
to approach the book is
to write a proposal or a
couple chapters and sell that.
You find a publisher with that.
I couldn't do that and the
reason I couldn't do that is
because I had no idea if
I would ever want the book
to be published.
And writing a couple chapters
or writing an outline,
I had no idea.
I just didn't know if
it was something that --
I felt like I had to
be fully convinced
that it would be a useful thing
[laughing] before I would want
to put it out there.
And I couldn't do that until
I'd written the whole thing.
I had to write every word of it.
And there were parts of it
that were hard for me to write
about that I didn't want
people to know about.
And in a way I needed the
rest of the story arc for me
to have the conviction.
I think it was worth
those things
that I didn't really
want to write.
And I would never have --
you know, that scene
in the parking lot
that I described is not
something I'm thrilled
that people know about me.
That's not fun.
But there are other things that
-- you know, there are other.
There's the end of that chapter.
And there's the realization
of what it meant
that is important to me.
And I can't have one
without the other.
And I had to write the
whole book and I had to say,
on the whole, is this
something I want out there?
But any individual chapter,
I guarantee you the
answer would have been no.
No, no, no, no.
>> Well, thank you
for writing it.
[Laughter]
>> Colleen Shogan: As we watch
you coming of age in the book,
a theme that emerges is
the difficulty surrounding
romantic relationships.
And as the book edges towards
conclusion it's indicated
that you formed a healthier
relationship with a man.
But that's kept pretty quiet.
And I was curious about
the choice not to talk more
about the emergence of that
relationship in the book
and that portion of
your coming of age.
>> Tara Westover: Yeah, I
thought about writing more
about that and in the
end I decided I just --
the book has so many
things going
on in it and so many themes.
And I wanted to provide
something that was useful
to people who struggle
with that because I did.
At BYU, you know, I'd had this
experience with my brother.
He had a nickname for me
that was -- it was "whore."
That's not a nice name to
call a 16-year-old girl.
That had really entered into
my self-definition in a way
that would, combined with a
lot of religious sexual guilt,
really make relationships
difficult
for me when I was at BYU.
And so I wrote about that
in the best terms I knew how
because I wanted people to
see, to feel what that was like
and to hopefully feel what it's
like to let that go and to see
where their own feelings
come from.
I didn't write -- you know, a
lot of people do write memoirs
about their kind of
sexual coming of age
and their lives like that.
And I didn't feel like
I had a lot to add.
I felt like the other
psychological things
that I explore in the book --
the letting go of certain
definitions that people have
of you, the letting
into your life of people
who aren't the stereotype
that you were taught.
You know, I think so
many of us form views
about what people are like.
Maybe we form a view
-- and I did this --
of what men are like
based on the men
that we've had in our lives.
And then we go out and we
find people in our lives
who are those men [laughing]
and it then confirms
the idea we have.
Well, men are like this and then
we're attracted to those people
and so we surround
ourselves with them.
And then it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy.
And I was lucky in that Drew
wasn't like that and the men
that I dated at BYU
weren't like that.
And slowly, by allowing
people into my life,
they allowed my ideas to change.
And I wanted to show
it that way.
I didn't particularly feel
the need to explore it
in any other detailed way.
I just wanted the idea to be
this is the idea I had of myself
and this is how it affected my
ability to connect with people.
And this is the way that
that slowly was let go of.
>> Thank you.
Hi. So, a fellow rural Idahoan.
>> Tara Westover: Welcome.
>> I was wondering.
You were talking about
your future project
with the transition
from rural education.
And I was wondering, based
on your own experience you talk
about, you know, going to BYU,
going to Cambridge, Harvard,
talking to President Obama,
all these things that there
really isn't this model
and you might feel like,
whoa, this is happening to me.
What kind of advice
or how did you deal
with jumping these hurdles
that just keep getting
higher and higher?
>> Tara Westover: I don't know!
[laughing]
[ Laughter ]
I kind of feel like -- I feel a
bit like my life is a video game
at the moment and things
keep happening that I feel
like will feel real eventually.
But right now, you know,
it's fun but it's kind
of like I'm dreaming that
these things are happening.
And there's a weird feeling
that it doesn't really matter
what I do because it's a dream.
[Laughing] And one of these
days I'm going to wake up
and realize, oh, no, that
all actually happened.
But no. I think change --
I've had a lot of experiences
in my life where things have
changed dramatically for me
and I suddenly had to
function in a new world.
And I had that at BYU.
And I had that at Cambridge.
And I kind of thought that I
was done with the catapult leaps
and just arriving somewhere that
I had no idea how to function.
And then this happened.
And it truly is one
of the weirdest things that's
ever happened to me [laughing].
And I don't have a strategy.
I kind of -- my strategy is
find things that make you feel
like yourself and stay
grounded and wait to catch up.
You know, your brain
will eventually catch up.
And until then, try
to remain calm.
[Laughter] And that's
what I'm doing right now.
I am trying to remain calm.
>> Thank you.
>> Next question.
>> In your book you go a lot
into how you learned the
good side of education.
Through college you started
learning more about the world.
But that can be taken
both ways in terms
of people can become more like
your brother and your father
through experiences they have
almost through bad education.
What is your opinion on that?
>> Tara Westover: I think
sometimes it's bad education.
Sometimes it's -- you know,
I speculate that my
father was bipolar
and I don't think he got what
he needed to deal with that.
And then, of course,
because he passes that on,
my brother Shawn was raised
in a stressful environment.
He had injuries, a number
of head injuries that he got
from working for my dad
that were never treated
or mostly not treated.
So I think, I don't know
as though I would say
if they got access to
the kind of education
that would have changed them.
And maybe they wouldn't
have changed.
But I think -- I guess I do
see it that way of I don't feel
like they had the
opportunities that they needed.
And I feel like I did.
And so I try not to
judge them so harshly
because they didn't get
the chances that I got.
And maybe they would have
made different decisions
and maybe there are reasons
for that and you can go
in that circle forever.
But I just feel like, I don't
know why they do the things
that they do.
I try not to be too judgmental.
But I also try to
have a clear line
of what I'll tolerate
for myself.
So I won't necessarily put
myself in that situation again,
even though I try not
to be so judgmental
of why they are the
way they are.
>> Alright.
Thank you.
>> Hi. You just mentioned
coming to kind
of understand your father
is potentially bipolar.
Throughout the book,
especially in the second half,
you kind of describe
a lot of experiences
that are also consistent in
yourself with PTSD and CTPSD.
And I was wondering if you
could talk a bit about,
if you are willing, how you
became aware of the kind
of lasting impact that some of
the things you went through had
and the process of recovery.
>> Tara Westover: Yeah.
I think the whole concept
of mental health is
wildly under-discussed.
It took me a really
long time to recognize
that I had symptoms of PTSD.
I think I had written
the book before
that was apparent
to me, actually.
I think I probably had someone
say it to me and I thought,
oh yeah, that's quite obvious.
[Laughing] Thank you.
Yeah. No, I think I've always
-- I resisted therapy violently
for a really long time
and now I love it.
And I don't -- people
say you have
to have somebody really good
and I think that's fine.
I find it valuable to have
anything, any excuse to sit down
and deal with the things that
otherwise you just repress
and don't think about.
I think it's for me
a very good thing.
Maybe other people think
it's better to repress it
but I think it's --
you take the health
of your physical body seriously.
So why not take the
health of your mind?
Like, why allow things
that happened to you
when you were a kid to determine
your life for 40 years?
Why do that?
Just take it seriously
and sort it out
and liberate yourself from that.
>> Thank you.
>> Colleen Shogan: Time
for one more question.
>> OK. Hi.
So something that was
hard for me to read
about in your book was how your
family manipulated religion
or religious language
in their relationships.
So I was wondering have you
been able to find your own faith
in God or spirituality?
>> Tara Westover: Yeah.
I put a note at the
beginning of the book
that says it's not a book about
Mormonism and the reason I did
that is because I didn't
want people to use this story
to caricaturize unkindly
people of faith in general.
My experience is people can be
very kind and very empathetic
or they can be very cold
and very self-serving.
And I haven't really noticed
that religion is the
determining factor for that.
For my own beliefs,
you know, I was raised
in a very extreme
religion and when I went
to mainstream Mormon faith,
I kind of converted to that
for a while and that didn't
sit perfectly with me either,
mostly because of gender issues.
And now I think for me the idea
of faith has just had
to bend a little bit.
It's just had to change.
And there's a really --
what I think of as one of
the key chapters of the book
which I've titled
after Hebrews 11:1 --
or it might be Hebrews 1:11.
And one of them is about a
dog, so it's not that one.
[ Laughter ]
But the one is that faith
is the substance of things,
the essence of things not seen.
And I think for anyone
who's had a difficult life,
who's had to say goodbye to
important people in their life,
who's trying to do those kind of
difficult psychological things,
I'm going to redefine
what I think romantic
relationships are.
I'm going to redefine what I
think family relationships are.
A lot of times you have
to believe in a world
that is not seen, that you
haven't experienced yet.
And that is true of
education and it's true
of many other things
where if you're reaching
for something better
and different
than what you have, it is faith.
That's what it is.
It's faith in something
that you haven't seen yet
but you choose to believe in it.
>> Colleen Shogan: Tara
will be signing copies
of her book downstairs
later this afternoon.
Please join me in thanking Tara
Westover for joining us today.
[ Applause ]